it's all quiet now but it won't be for
long because the sixteen houseguests
will be here on Tuesday night on CBS but
we have a first look for you tonight
right now because my good friend Julie
Chen the host of the show gave us a
private tour ket welcome to the
brand-new Big Brother house this summer
the theme it's all about camp sixteen
houseguests 99 days and 94 cameras
watching their every move for season 21
big brother is bringing the great
outdoors inside check out the dining
room table with a fire pit there's a
trailer inside one of the bedrooms and
something else new this season the first
time ever we have two ways to get
upstairs I'm gonna take the new way the
ladder I'll meet you up there
this is formerly known as the upstairs
lounge this year at camp it's our tree
house we've got some brand new additions
we've got brand new fish we've also got
some new games we add and this is this
Sears HOH bedroom the head of household
has their own private bedroom and
bathroom and keeping with the camping
theme the bed is covered by a tent
it is glamping to the max one more thing
these three massive steel elk sculptures
in the living room now there are no
cameras in them they're not alive but
this is big brother so they always could
be watching
you